- Thanks, guys.
- Appreciate it.
- Good afternoon, everyone.
And in the next 20 minutes,
we are going to talk about
how to
change the future of business,
how we do through the autonomous
enterprise operations?
The way we are structured,
the discussion for next 20 minutes
is then Todd will come and
talk about as a partnership
what we are doing together with AWS.
Just before we start the presentation,
I want to thank one of my
customers here from Kenvue.
He's the vice president from Kenvue,
and they are a user of Ignio.
Thank you very much
for being our customer.
Pravin has been a great help.
And any one of you who
wants to discuss with him
post the event, he would be
happy to spend some time.
This morning, today also,
we announced a partnership with Control-M,
which is the first inaugural
launch, along with AWS,
on their marketplace
as a multiproduct SaaS,
which we launched today.
Go and check it out.
But coming to this presentation,
we'll just talk about three stories,
what we are doing.
That will give you a sense
of how the customers are using those.
And then, we will tell you
what the product is about,
then we'll sum up the story
and then hand it over to Todd.
I'm sure somebody can recognize:
it's a premium retail company, Tapestry.
The bags, which some of you
might have seen, used it.
They had a issue where some of the orders
are not reaching on time,
not being processed,
not being fulfilled,
not delivered on time.
It's a loss of revenue,
loss of experience.
Another example we'll
talk about is this company
which is in the med-tech space.
They manufacturer prosthetic limbs.
And if those limbs, the commit
date to the surgery room
in the hospital is not confirmed,
the surgery may not happen
and the patient may not get their limbs.
And the third example is,
let's say in Bangalore,
there's a cricket match going on,
a T20 cricket match,
and a lot of the retailers
nearby are stocking
so that they feel that they will have
a lot of sales going on.
And that sales, the stock is not fulfilled
because there's some certain glitch,
because the intended CPG company
is not able to fulfill those
because of certain
order processing issues.
In all these three examples,
there is something common
as a business problem.
Underneath somewhere,
the IT did not perform
the way it was designed to perform.
And that's the challenge we
see, we all know and cross
when the business calls you,
that look, something did not work.
My order did not get processed,
and you see IT problem has happened.
So majority of the business problem today,
what you see is a technology issue.
And that's what we are trying to solve
and make it autonomous in the industry.
If you look at the example of Tapestry,
which I talked about,
their challenge was they have
37 different storefronts.
They operate globally.
Orders comes to those storefronts,
they have a order management system,
they have a fulfillment process,
they have a financial
transaction to close,
and then the shipping happens.
And in the whole journey,
if you look at, there are different hubs
where the data flow
through different systems,
and as a technology layer
and within some of the application itself,
for example, SAP systems
and other systems.
And in that journey of the data flow,
we have deployed identified observability
to ensure that every hop
the business knows exactly
how the order is processing.
And if something goes wrong
at the layer of technology,
the technology team also knows
which component of technology has failed
or not performed to the expectation,
and that's why that problem
has been creeped in.
And in all this area, if you see,
this problem has resulted
and we have, you know,
some data, which I'll
share to you this morning,
which came from the last week itself,
because last week was a
very heightened activity
because of Black Friday sales
and what was going on
everywhere in the world.
In last one week, they processed
more than a million orders.
And if Ignio was not there,
almost worth $3 million
worth of their order
either would not have been processed,
they might have been delayed,
or they might have been
canceled by the consumers
because they might not have
made the promised date.
So that's the value.
What we are bringing in this situation,
we are bringing the unified observability
across the process flow
from order to cash,
and underlying technology vertically
from the tech as perspective,
to ensure the operational autonomy
is involved and delivered
to them every day,
every time order comes through.
The second example, which I talked about,
the challenge was this company
grew through acquisition several years.
It's a longstanding brand.
They build, as I said, prosthetic limbs.
They're across the supply chain,
and demand planning specifically.
They have to confirm a promise date
for a specific limb to a
patient and to the surgeon.
And if you look at that
area, it's very, you know,
humble to speak about that
because you need four things:
you need a doctor, you need a hospital,
you need a patient, and you need the limb.
All three are available,
the limb is not available,
the promise date is not there.
That's the challenge that customer had
where this order flow of
data was happening through,
there were 70 different interfaces
because they have grown
through acquisition,
different applications, different kinds,
SaaS, on-premise,
antiquated, you know, legacy application,
all running through those systems,
that's what we have solved for them.
Where the data flow happens,
the demand planning process for them
has been reduced from weeks to now hours,
and they're able to promise
the date to the hospitals
so that the surgery can happen.
And that's what is a big help,
not only to my customer here,
but it's also to the end user,
because that's very
important for their life.
The third example
I talked about, you know,
it's an example where,
I know, and some of you
who work in the retail or CPG industry,
the direct store delivery
is a very, very critical process
for some of the CPC companies.
And in that process, typically,
route sales would go take the orders,
see the stock on the shelf,
understand what is required,
how it's selling,
punch in some orders there;
that order flows through
different systems,
comes to the CPC company, to
their manufacturing units,
and ship through the truck, goes,
and it directly stock on the shelf.
That is a very high-frequency process
where if you miss or
order is not delivered,
as simple as a manifest
has not been generated,
and your truck may not fill
the full orders and move.
You have lost two parts in that process.
First of all, the shelf
is empty for the retailer.
The retailer has not only lost the revenue
and the CPG company-associated revenue,
but you also lose the
brand and the market share.
And it's a very, very competitive market.
So on that journey, on the business value,
what we are monitoring, what we call it,
on the whole journey of
right from the order taker
to the manufacturing plant,
to the shipping fulfillment,
and us really stocking.
The whole journey we have mapped on Ignio,
which is the platform from this state
to ensure on a weekly basis we process
couple of hundred
million dollars of orders
on this platform,
to ensure it moves
autonomously in the journey.
Now, these three stories
are from different kind I talked about.
You know, it matters as a business.
Underneath all this real solution,
real-life solution is the
technology was the problem.
And I'll come to the next part,
how we are solving this problem today.
So as I said, autonomous
is the new operating model,
how we are delivering that value.
And I'm sure some of you who
comes from the IT background,
you all want to eliminate
business disruption
which happens because of IT.
A lot of business folks call you and say,
"Look, I gave you all t?he tools.
Why this happened again?"
The second party want to still do.
If we can't fix those problem proactively,
that I should know first as an IT
before business partner knows.
And I can tell them in
advance that I know it,
we are fixing it.
If you can't do that,
the last and the least part you can do
is if I know somebody called
me a problem has been there,
can I recover as fast as possible
that the problem feels like a blip?
And to achieve these three elements
in the order of priority,
we have built a platform called Ignio
which has three broad things.
One is the identified observability
which I talked about from
the horizontal observability
to understand the layer of data processing
which happens through
different applications.
And then identifying
vertical stack observability
to understand how the problem occurs
and proactively create the visibility
and avoid those problems from
happening at the first place.
We also hook up on the second part,
which he talked about,
the AI-driven insight.
We hook up with lot of telemetry data,
log data and other elements
which comes from the environment
through your monitoring tools,
to understand what can happen.
And we can predict what's going to fail.
For example, this application,
the way the usage is
increasing six weeks from now,
the performance of this
service is going to degrade.
It gives you some latitude
to understand what's
going on, a bad job cycle.
It can tell you 3:00 AM
in the morning and say,
"Look, by 6:00 AM your
sales reconciliation report
is not going to come.
It will miss that KPI."
That's what this AI-driven
insight gives you the time
so that you can recover
from those situation
before the problem has already hit you.
And the third part is problem will do,
occur we recognize.
And that's where the
closed-loop automation comes,
where a problem has resurfaced,
Ignio understands the context,
it understands the whole hierarchy model
of your enterprise as IT blueprint,
and it can recover and isolate the problem
at a machine speed,
which typically today,
lot of environment today,
all the enterprise customers,
they put teams which are siloed in nature,
they come together;
typically, first time they will say,
the network guys, they're the fault.
Eventually they come down to
some database guy and say,
"Look, the-long-running
query is the problem.
Then fix it."
It takes maybe an hour to
two hour to four hours.
That's where it runs at a machine speed,
isolate the problem.
And then we have built almost
10,000 automated actions
to take action to fix this
problem within minutes.
So that situation, which
takes maybe an hour, two hour,
five hour to fix, can be
solved in couple of minutes,
maybe sometimes three
minutes, sometimes 10 minutes.
All these three elements
of the capability,
what we have built on this platform
is applied to your cloud operations,
your typical data center,
if you have a data center
in your environment,
custom application, SAP systems, bad jobs,
and devices like laptops and desktops.
And that pretty much covers
your 80 to 90% of operations.
And that's what our vision has been,
to go behind this and make
all the journey autonomous
so that the business can perform
the way it's supposed to perform.
And to deliver all this, what
we have is this five agents,
the whole architecture agentic,
if you look at some of the personas
which we deal in the enterprise today,
the SRS persona, the
CXO personas, you know,
a lot of cloud operation which goes on,
a lot of IT operations team handles.
And their objectives,
which I've touched about,
is very clear, move as fast as you could,
avoid, eliminate the incidents.
And these five agents works
in a very simple principle
that they can work on their own.
And these agents are made
through six subagents.
All agents are through a perception agent,
a reasoning agent, an action
agent, and a learning agent.
And we also have built a control agent
and a LLM-based model agent,
so that it augment some of the teams.
Because maybe Ignio does
not have the full knowledge,
100% knowledge of everything
goes into the enterprise.
So what we have built here
from the agentic platform perspective,
not only a deterministic model
where it can go and fix certain problems
from the logical reasoning perspective,
but it can also take
something analytical model
through your LLMs.
We use
one of the other platform
from an LLM today,
and that we can bring it together
from the logical and logical
model to fix the problems,
what goes on in your enterprise.
So on that note, just to give
you some data points today,
we are very focused on
the global 2000 customer.
We believe enterprise is the
segment where we thrive well.
The impact of the value of
this platform is much higher.
The value was there
derived, it's much bigger.
We are almost managing
34,200 workload globally
in 20 different region.
We process almost 1.2 billion
events on this platform
with almost 87% noise reduction.
Just imagine the help it gives
to the command center team everywhere.
We almost have 300
million-plus automation,
which is working today on
the platform every year.
And of course we are compliant
to certain standards,
global standards with any
enterprise needed today:
SOC 2, Type 2 and others.
Of course, on that journey,
AWS has been a great
partner, as I talked about.
We have launched today
morning with BMC Control-M.
But I'll ask Todd to talk
about some of the partnership,
what we have gone through
in last several years.
- Sure. Thanks.
Thanks, Rajiv. Great stuff.
So good afternoon. My name is Todd Carey.
I lead our GSP sales teams worldwide.
And really, that's two main areas,
is looking at our biggest partners
and strategic partners as customers,
and then also as investors and sellers
and how we go to market together.
And that really is responding
to a lot of the market signals,
the things that we see,
things that customers demand.
So it's amazing to hook up
with partners like Digitate,
where they're looking at things,
they're building things,
but most importantly
they're delivering things.
And when we are like delivering
things like outcomes,
and we start talking
about on-time deliveries,
weeks to hours, full trucks,
you know, these are use cases
that end customers really
want to hear about.
And in fact, just as important,
is our field sales teams
want to hear about it.
So when you're an end customer
or you're an AWS or
you're another partner,
what good looks like
definitely is Digitate.
And these are the partners
that we really lean in with
and support from a
go-to-market standpoint,
from a solution-building standpoint.
And we figure out how
we can scale together.
So it's a great success story.
And Digitate and Ignio
leveraging the marketplace,
BMC, leveraging AWS Marketplace.
This is really the next
generation of sales platform.
So if anyone got to hear Matt Wise,
Matt Yintinson's keynote on Marketplace,
and all of the new
announcements that we're making.
You know, from a next-generation sales
and a next-generation
experience and engagement,
you take an Ignio and you
take a Digitate and an AWS,
and it's an extremely
powerful combination.
And delivering value on time,
and most importantly, delivering outcomes.
So we look at the type of
partner that we want to look for
and we want to invest in,
and Digitate certainly represents that.
And so we're always exploring
how we unlock value,
how we accelerate time to value,
and we accelerate time to market.
And as a complete package of
partnership and relationship,
super excited to be supportive of Digitate
and all that they're doing in the market.
So just as a quick say hi.
And a huge endorsement of all the things
that we're doing with Digitate.
So very excited.
And I think we're gonna
open up to some Q&A,
right?
- Sure.
If you have a question,
we can answer them.
- There's some questions.
Happy to field all of those.
Was it that thorough?
Ah.
- Maybe.
- Rajiv, good stuff.
To be able to deliver
that with no questions.
- Okay.
- Thank you very much.
- [Todd] I think that's a wrap.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
(attendees applauding)
- Alright. Good job.
- Thank you.